Hello everybody.
My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Buried.
Now this going to be a different type of let's play
because this is an interactive story.
And, it could be considered a game by many
and I consider it to be a game, but also...
It involves narration -
no physical actions to be taken...
and a lot of choices that determine your ending.
I don't even know how many endings are in this game
but it's a branching narrative... that covers five chapters.
And it could be something... really in depth.
So let's begin.
There's no time to wait around. We've got a lot of choices to make.
Also, the thing about these interactive stories is
while the visuals may be limited in terms of pictures and text,
the audio... is where it's really at.
So I recommend you guys put on headphones,
turn up your audio...
And get ready... for a nice... story... with Markiplier.
(Narrating) I open my eyes, and the first thing I want to do is scream.
I'm flat on my back and everything seems to hurt.
The trees overhead look familiar.
It's a clear night sky, almost beautiful...
Except for the fact that this means I've been out cold for at least six hours.
But there's something wrong...
I don't remember what, but something happened and...
My head... my god! My head hurts.
And a ringing in my ears. Was there an accident? An explosion, I think.
I remember Dennis screaming, but after that I can't remember...
As I sit up, I notice that my hard hat has been thrown off.
I look around the area but it's not here.
It feels strange to go anywhere without my hard hat...
But I've gotta find the other members of the crew.
They could be in danger.
(Speaking normally) So I say...
You might waste time looking for the hard hat,
so it's best just to go for the crew.
You've already been through an explosion and you survived, so I know this guy's tough.
I know that *I'm* tough.
(Narrating) I decide that my hat can wait until I figure out what's going on.
I get up and take a look around the logging site.
I smell something burning... and don't hear any engines running.
Wait - something isn't right.
Was it the bulldozer?
Maybe the damn thing overheated for the last time; maybe the engine finally blew.
What a mess... Well maybe I'm jumping to conclusions -
only one way to find out I guess.
I walk over to the center of the logging site... and dont like what I see.
(Speaking normally) Dead bodies?
I'm guessing it's gonna be dead bodies
Oh!
Well that's not good.
Ooh - shit...
(Narrating) The logging site looks like a bomb was detonated right in the center.
I dont know where to start.
The one load we'd managed to stack on a truck for the day is overturned.
The trailer bent, and the log's hanging off the back.
Where the hell is everyone?
My head is *killing* me and this *ringing* in my ears...
I can't hear anything. Not birds, not my footsteps - nothing...
It makes me wonder if I hit my head after my hard hat flew off.
I run through a quick mental checklist to make sure my brain is still working.
My name is Roger Hastings. I'm 41 years old... The year is 2017.
I own a small logging camp and we'd been logging in this strip of Kentucky woodland for almost a month now.
OK, so my brain works - that's a relief...
But it also makes me fearful... because something is certainly not right here.
I look around the logging camp - my mind trying to figure out what has happened.
Just about every piece of equipment has been overturned or tilted.
(Speaking normally) Okay, so would it be more important to look at the debris...
Or look at the truck?
I mean, we can see the truck...
But I think looking at the debris would give a clue to actually what happened here.
At least that's... *my* conclusion.
(Narrating) There are bits of debris everywhere.
There're fragments of the 5-gallon bucket I keep our work rags in...
A loose saw chain, and an overturned gas canister.
Had there been an explosion, all the fuel on site would have started a fire,
but there's no charring, no burning - nothing.
I walk through the area where Dennis had been working.
From the looks of it, he'd been moving *slowly*...
He'd only taken down four trees today.
His metal lunch box was open -
an indicator that he had been taking an early break - but he's not here.
*No one* is here.
Where the *hell* is everyone?
I could try to make a call on my cell phone, but its battery is already running really low.
Not that it matters; the reception is crap out here.
(Speaking normally) So... it looks like...
Calling someone on the cell phone might actually be a *bad* idea - all things considered -
Because it *seems* - to *me* anyway - that that's obviously not going to work
because the reception is bad and I might save my phone battery for something else.
So I'm gonna yell out.
I'm gonna yell and see if anybody nearby.
HEY GUYS! WHERE IS EVERYONE?
TONY, DENNIS, FRANK, JOE!
But their names fall flat among the wreckage.
I get nothing back other than scaring away a few birds overhead.
Might as well start walking, try to find some answers.
The highway is almost a mile back through the woods, down the gravel road we used to reach the site.
Maybe the crew ran that way for help.
But why would they have left me...? Were they scared? Out of sorts?
Maybe I can catch up to them. But with my truck turned over on its side, it looks like I'll be walking.
My god, I can't even remember what I was doing before waking up on my back.
Wait what's that underneath the bulldozer?
Oh my god! It's a leg.
It has to be either Tony or Dennis.
The dozer looks unstable, like it might roll some more.
Might not be safe to get close, but at the same time, I can't just leave him there.
(Speaking normally) Well...
All things considered they might be dead, but y'know what it's worth the risk to go look.
...I'm thinking.
(Narrating) "HEY!" I yell, "Are you OK? Are you alive?"
I skip over the stray logs and wrecked equipment to get closer.
Seeing the dozer teeter makes me think... maybe I should've grabbed my hat.
I can see a bit more of the leg; the jeans are soaked in blood.
I recognize the work boots; it's clearly Tony.
His leg is bent at an impossible angle, nearly crushed flat.
The closer I get, the more apparent it becomes that Tony didn't survive.
(Speaking normally) Best not to pull the body out! I mean, I get -
It's his friend, it's his co-worker... but he's obviously dead.
There's no use in trying to... pull his body out, to try to get the -- the dozer will tip over.
No, no need to do that.
There's nothing I can do for him now. I start to back away slowly.
In my shock, I stumble back, suddenly tripping over one of the stray logs.
I bang my head hard on one of the logs as I fall.
I instantly feel a massive lump forming on the back of my head.
Damn... Why didn't I grab my hard hat?
But what hurts more is the realization that Tony is dead.
Looking at him I feel something rising up in my throat. I don't know if it's a scream or vomit.
But I have to push it away... if I lose my cool right now, there are too many questions that will go unanswered.
Shit - I can't believe this. Tony... he had two boys.
He coached his oldest son's baseball team.
He was the hardest worker I had and was one of the most honest and reliable men I knew. This isn't right.
I can't stay here. I have to find Dennis, Frank, and Joe. I have to find out what happened here.
(Speaking normally) So, I made a goof and didn't grab a hard hat, but I think...
MAYBE... things might have been different if I did.
(Narrating) As I walked through the stacks of logs from the last week or so, everything feels frozen.
This high-pitched sound in my ears - it's terrible.
Keeps happening every few seconds like it's coming from far away.
I can't help but wonder, is it my ears... or is it something else?
The silence out here is creepy, and there's a smell... like the atmosphere after a bad summer storm.
I might as well admit it - I'm a little scared. Everyone is missing and it's dead quiet out here.
There doesn't even seem to be a breeze to rustle the leaves and branches.
My right knee hurts like hell. My head was hurting so bad before... that I never even noticed the pain in my knee.
I must have hurt it during the...well, during the what? Accident? Or...
Wait, is that Dennis...? I see him sitting on the ground, motionless, about thirty... feet away.
(Speakingnormally) Y'know what? Best not to -- best not to sneak up on him.
I'm gonna yell; I'm gonna yell in case it's not Dennis.
Hey -- HEEEY! ARE YOU A MONSTER, DENNIS?
CAN YOU HEAR ME?
(Narrating) Dennis lets out a shout, like someone waking from a nightmare.
He then looks back at me from the ground.
Yeah Roger, I can hear you... he hollers back as I head over to him.
Dennis is built like a wrestler... and has the tough personality to match.
But in this moment he looks disoriented and even a little anxious.
Though I'm glad to see him, the fear on his usually confident face is alarming.
What the hell happened? What's going on? He asks.
(Speaking normally) I'm not willing to bet it's an explosion.
I'll just say I don't know -- don't know - the crew is missing.
Tony's dead.
(Narrating) Missing? Where do you think they went?
I'm not sure, I say... but it has me pretty freaked out - something's not right here.
Still sitting on the ground, he looks around the woods...
As if he's just now understanding the severity of the situation.
The equipment was overturned, the dozers too, I say - wiping my forehead.
You okay? I ask him. Yeah... just shaken up.
Me too.
This might be the most intimate conversation Dennis and I ever had.
While he and I have always been on good terms, we've never been particularly close.
I've always respected him though.
Sure, he's come to work a few times looking like he'd been in a bar fight the night before...
But I've also seen him do...
an enthusiastic impression of a dinosaur as he played with Tony's kid while they waited for their dad to finish up his shift.
It's then that it hits me... Dennis and Tony were good friends.
I'm not sure I want to rattle him with the news of Tony's death right now.
Not  before we know what's going on, but he has the right to know.
(Speaking normally) Oh!
Yeah - you don't withhold that kind of information from someone.
You don't; you just don't.
Tony's dead.
(Narrating) You were upfront with Dennis about Tony.
Dennis's eyes fixate on me - startled.
He -- he was crushed under the dozer, I say.
Dennis pauses for a moment like he's trying to understand what I said.
His eyes narrow and his bottom lip quivers.
Shit, he says. And I can tell that he's fighting back tears.
He and Tony had been tight - almost like brothers.
Hey, he adds quickly as if trying to escape reality.
Did you see that light?
No, what did you see?
I don't even know, Roger.
It was like this flare of white light; it came right up out of the ground -
Like an explosion.
So there *was* an explosion, I say.
Maybe it was some equipment or --
This was *no* equipment... This huge ball of light came right out of the damn ground.
(Speaking normally) What did it look like? It looked like a ball of light so...
Might as well ask where it went.
He already said what it looked like.
(Narrating) Where'd it go?
It just shot up into the sky until it was out of sight.
When?
I'm not sure... but I'd finished about ten trees for the day and was about to top one.
That's when it happened.
You were almost done with ten trees? I ask.
Yeah... y'know I wouldn't want to take a lunch break until I was done.
And that's when that light blew up. Why? You don't believe me?
(Speaking normally) No, no.
I *believe* you Dennis. I believe you one hundred percent.
(Narrating) You *believe* Dennis's story
(Interjecting) Yeah!
(Narrating) He saw... what he saw... I think to myself.
He has no reason to lie about it.
My god - are you okay?
Yeah, I'm fine... But if I'm being honest, it scared me pretty bad.
And if it's all the same to you, I'd like to get the hell out of here.
We both stand up and start heading towards the road.
It isn't until we start moving that I see Dennis is wounded.
His right side is coated with blood - the red seeping through his blue work shirt.
There're splatters of it here and there... but also a very large red splotch... that makes me worry.
(Speaking normally) If I ask him if he's gonna be in a lot of pain, the big tough guy ain't gonna say he is.
I'm just gonna ask how he got it. What happened?
(Narrating) I'm not sure; I must have gotten thrown or hurt somewhat from that... light.
It's then that I noticed the strange ringing noises still filling the air.
Hey, do you hear that high pitched ringing noise every once in a while?
Dennis looks *scared* when I ask him this question and he just nods.
I thought it was just me, he says.
He looks out of sorts and uncertain. I've never seen him like this before.
It's obvious that he's looking for some reassurance.
Even though I'm his boss, there's something very unnerving about this.
We'll be OK. It's probably nothing.
(Speaking normally) There's no reason to worry the guy. It's obvious he's shaken up.
There's no reason to make him paranoid about whatever the noise is.
I mean - it is what it is. We'll get to the bottom of it no matter what, but... he needs -- he needs some comfort after the bad news.
(Narrating) Let's be realistic, I tell myself. I might as well try to be empathetic.
Out here in the middle of these woods, the ringing could be anything -
Maybe a car alarm from through the woods or somethin'.
Still, even my passive comment seems to have reassured Dennis.
He looks a bit calmer - more relaxed.
We both start moving forward and don't say another word.
Did you try to call Frank? I know he had his cell on him today.
Not yet. Luckily I still have some battery left.
I pull out my cell and call Frank - happy I didn't make that call to Dennis earlier.
It rings, but he doesn't pick up...
But when I hear his phone go off behind the stack of logs, Dennis and I give each other a look.
As the phone goes to voice mail, I hang up and we walk behind the logs... to find Frank's phone on the ground abandoned.
We look around for Frank but find nothing - not a single trace.
It's then that I notice something really odd - a ten foot wide hole... in the ground right  near where the phone was.
But there's no stray piles of removed dirt or rocks. It's clean - smoothly done - cutting into the earth... wide, but only a few feet deep.
It looks unnatural, like the ground was just deleted - no shovels or diggers used.
Dennis walks over to it.
This looks like the same kinda hole where I saw that light come from the ground.
I say nothing. My mind is spinning but I don't know what to think.
We need to get out of here, Dennis mutters.
At this moment, that ringing noise carries through the forest again sending a shiver down my spine.
Dennis is right; there's something strange going on, and we might not be safe here...
But that ringing sound could be a clue to where the rest of the crew went.
(Speaking normally) To be perfectly honest, we can't run away from the situation. We're already in the middle of it.
If you're in the middle of it, I -- I guess it would be the first inclination to go to safety, but Frank is still out there and he *could*... be alive.
Tony is dead but... we gotta find Frank. And the only clue that we got is checking out the sound.
(Narrating) You decide to check out the sound.
Something's not right, and if there's a mechanical noise like that...
You think someone is out there? he asks.
Maybe. I think we should at least check it out. They might be able to help.
Yeah, you go right ahead, he says with a grin. I'll be waiting for you here... Better hurry though.
Dennis doesn't look like he's in the best shape to be trouncing around the forest,
but we need some answers right away too.
(Speaking normally) I didn't know that we'd be... splitting up.
Ughh, splitting up is like the worst thing to do...
But if I leave him here, is he gonna be okay?
Best to stick together, but he *is* wounded. Man - this is a bad choice.
I mean - if we were gonna get out of here, then he'd have to go anyway, so... Dennis has gotta come. I can't leave him behind.
(Narrating) No, you're coming with me.
I bend over and hoist him up against my shoulder. He resists just barely and then gives in.
He's looking at me like he's terrified of me now - making a moan in his throat.
We start moving through the woods quickly.
With no idea where the rest of the crew is, I worry they could be in danger.
Every tree out here looks exactly the same.
I grew up in the country and could find my way around the forest without much of a problem, but I'm feeling dizzy.
I'm leaning against a tree when I see something that has no business being out here.
Our logging crew has been out here for three weeks and I've *never* seen it before.
(Speaking normally) What is it? Somethin'... *dastardly*... in the darkness?
Whoa.
(Narrating) It's a small building - sorta like a mixture of a shack and a bunker.
It looks to be made of concrete but moss, weeds, and plain old erosion has made it... look sort of mystical.
It looks like something out of a demented version of a medieval fantasy movie.
The hell is this? Dennis asks.
(Speaking normally) I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna make a guess - I don't know.
How would -- how'd I know?
You purchased this land, right boss? Didn't you survey it?
I certainly did...! I say getting a little defensive. But this wasn't here.
Do you think the others... maybe went in here? (he asks nervously)
Why would they do that?
I don't know, but they aren't out here. If they aren't inside, they're probably dead...
Like Tony.
He looks at the ground as he says this.
I wanna go inside not just to find my crew but also to appease my curiosity.
That ringing noise is coming from inside.
But something about this place seems incredibly strange...
Especially located all by itself out here - it simply doesn't belong.
I wonder, do we knock or just go in?
I can tell that he's trying to make a joke but it falls flat.
I'm starting to think his humor is a defense mechanism for his fear.
We both look ahead, take a moment to realize what we're about to do and start forward.
We get no more than three feet closer when Dennis wobbles.
(Speaking normally) Reach out to steady him.
He's not gonna ask for help - big, tough guy like that.
(Narrating) I reach out quickly, straining my injured knee.
I barely make it in time, grabbing him under his arms and keeping him from hitting the ground.
I'm okay, he said. Just -- can you help me walk for a little while? Just help me inside please.
I can't deny him his request. I've never seen him this weak and it's a little uncomfortable to see.
Makes me glad I decided to keep him with me.
I help Dennis into the weird little building. The front door opens easily even though there's clearly a lock on it.
Maybe the lock was supposed to keep someone in. It's hard to tell.
I still hear that ringing noise. It's definitely coming from in there.
Stretching out in front of me is a small interior to match the outside.
The building is totally empty. There's a concrete floor and dingy... featureless walls.
There are no windows... giving the place an even more isolated feel.
Still, we hear the ringing noise coming from somewhere in here. It's *louder* now - more prominent.
The interior seems confined at first, but a small set of concrete steps leads about five feet down...
Revealing a corridor.
(Speaking normally) I don't know about you guys but I am *enthralled* with this.
And I'm already seeing - like - how my choices could have *drastically* changed the story...
And there's a lotta choices.
(Narrating) It's... a massive corridor in fact - like I'm in some kind of building underground. It seems to go on forever.
This corridor is mostly dark with emergency lights every ten feet or so.
I assume we're now underground because this corridor extends far beyond the walls of the building we entered.
I realize that someone might not appreciate finding us here.
(Speaking normally) Well... we can't exactly walk quickly 'cause - I mean - Dennis is hurt.
So, might as well go quiet.
(Narrating) I feel like a ghost - like I truly have no business here.
Dennis leans on me for support. We move slowly - our feet not making a sound.
If anyone is in here, I want to make sure they don't hear us.
We tiptoe forward as softly as we can.
As I carry Dennis to the far end of this otherwise featureless place,
I see a flight of concrete stairs lending down.
I have to set Dennis down on the floor. His weight is killing me.
Dennis, are you okay?
Stop worrying man. I'll be okay; I just need a minute to rest.
But looking at him I'm not so sure.
I can still hear the ringing noise every so often - coming from somewhere in here.
I look ahead at the concrete stairs pointing towards them, so that Dennis sees them.
Can you make it down those stairs? I ask.
He stands up slowly and is visibly making an effort to not fall back down again.
Yeah, he says... sounds a little irritated.
He starts for the stairs without me and I have no choice but to follow.
We approach the stairs and by just looking at them...
I get the sense that we're crossing some sort of line here.
There may very well be no going back.
(Speaking normally) Well! Might as well keep moving forward then.
Not much of a choice to be --
Ooh... that reminds me of SCP.
What was it? The stair one - 087B?
(Narrating) As I head down the stairs, I notice that they look aged.
The damn ringing noises somewhere below... louder than ever.
I feel like I'm walking down into the cellar of a haunted house -
The light becoming scarce as the stairs take a slight turn.
I can feel the temperature drop.
Dennis makes it just a few steps down before he's leaning on the wall.
He's breathing like he just finished a marathon.
(Speaking normally) I gotta give him a break. He's pushing himself. He's probably losing blood.
I gotta take a break.
Let's take a break I say - putting my hand towards his shoulder to help steady him.
Dennis lets out a sigh.
Thanks. I don't feel too great, boss.
As we both squat down on a stair, my mind seems to lock in on the unknown fate of the rest of my crew.
Frank is married and I met his wife a few times - a nice woman with a huge laugh.
My heart sags a bit when I realize I might never get to hear him belting out a classic... rock tunes during lunch break.
Joe.
Well, I don't know too much about him. He's twenty two years old and is considering community college.
His folks are deadbeats so he'd been providing for himself since the age of sixteen.
Maybe I can still find them... and still get to hear Frank singing in his deep baritone voice after a few too many drinks.
After a few moments, Dennis says: Alright, let's keep goin'.
We both stand up - leaning on each other.
I have to make Dennis stay behind me as I stick my foot out in search of the next step.
I can't help feeling like a child as a very powerful fear seizes me.
I'm expecting a monster to reach out of the darkness...
Slicing into my throat.
After what feels like forever, we come to the bottom of the stairs.
We're closer to that ringing noise now.
A door sits securely in the wall and looks just as out of place down here as I feel.
A sliver of light seeps through - illuminating the area.
The door has what looks like a panel with a lot of labels and lights.
Small embossed print above the panel says... level one... entrance gate. Transport sector.
And there's a button with no label.
(Speaking strangely) *Bes~vehh* -- best not to be pushing random buttons!
Let's inspect the panel first.
(Narrating) The panel looks like some kind of diagnostic or alert system of some kind -
Each label meant to communicate some status.
Lockdown engaged, experiment in progress, shutdown engaged...
All these appear to be off, but one of the phrases has a slowly blinking red light next to it -
The only powered light on this whole thing.
*Abnormal* entity breach.
What the hell?
I slowly push the door open then Dennis suddenly steps in front of me - taking the lead.
Let's go, he says.
I wanna find out what the hell this place is.
As Dennis walks through, that ringing or beeping or whatever it was gets a little louder.
The door closes behind us with a click.
I can't help but notice the wobble in Dennis's step as he lets out a grunt.
You sure you're healthy enough to keep going? I ask.
It doesn't matter. I don't want to be in the woods right now.
He seems scared - something I've never seen before.
Angry - yes. Upset - yes. But Dennis is never... *scared*.
What did you see?
(Speaking normally) What did he see in those woods?
(Narrating) I don't know what it was, boss. It was like something --
Someone'd left a radio on - crackling.
But we don't have any radios at the site.
It was -- I dunno...!
It was like something in the forest was *moving*.
I gave him a doubtful look and he cast his eyes to the ground - frustrated.
I know how it sounds, but I know what I felt.
It was like walking into a funeral parlor -
Feeling *death* and gloom everywhere.
I've never been so preoccupied with my own fear that I nearly forgot about the ringing noise.
It'd just become background noise.
We took a few more steps and I can now see where we are.
It makes no sense.
Yet another thing that simply seems out of place.
The shapes and muted colors of metal are easy to identify, but it just doesn't belong here.
END! - of chapter one.
(Speaking normally) Well. That is the end of chapter one...
And... that's fascinating.
I -- ih -- I -- I didn't expect it to be something like this, but the story... is really interesting.
(Reading) Respect the dead.
You and thirty-six... percent of players left Tony's body where you found it.
You and seventy-six... percent of players were upfront about Dennis about Tony's death.
You and fifty-five percent told Dennis you believed his story.
You and seventy-five percent of players went to investigate the ringing sound.
You and sixty-four percent of players decided to bring Dennis... *with* you.
(Not reading) That's fascinating.
So, anyway - I'm gonna end this one here.
Lemme know what you guys think of this, 'cause this is a different type of game...
but I'm already fascinated about what's going on here.
I really kinda wanna continue this, and I could make this an easy five part series.
It'd just be... really interesting to see what it leads to, because...
If I'm not mistaken here,
this almost seems like an SC -- Containment Breach type thing.
It said "abnormal entity breach"...
Or escape... or whatever that was...
And it's some *weird* facility that's *underground* with some *strange* mechanical *containment* type features...
It may not be exactly related but... you can't help but see some of the similarities.
And anything with SCP Containment Breach... is a fascinating experience.
So, once again...!
Let me know what you thought of this down in the comments below - I really do wanna know.
And I really do wanna know if you guys want to see more.
So, *thank you* everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will see you...
In the next video!
BUH-BYE!